It looks like Maura didn't really get anywhere by adding
age as color to her plot. But I want you to
know that's okay. Sometimes when we conduct exploratory data analysis
we do reach dead ends. Let's see if we can get
any further in examining our relationship between friends count and
age by adding a third variable. Previously we noted that female
users have more friends on average than male users. And, we
might wonder, is this just because female users have a different
age distribution? Or, maybe conditional on age, the differences
are actually larger. Here's a box plot of ages by
gender. Now, I'm going to add the mean for
each gender to the box plots, using stat summary. Here
we can see the averages marked by an x
since I used shape=4. Since male users are a bit
younger, we might actually think a simple male to
female comparison doesn't capture their substantial differences in friend count.
Let's look at median friend count by age and gender instead.
A lot of this code should look familiar, and if it doesn't,
I want you to post any questions that you have about
it in a discussion. When I run this code, we can see
that nearly everywhere the median friend count is larger for women
than it is for men. Now there are some exceptions, and this
includes these noisy estimates for our very old users. Now, I'm
using old with quotation marks here, since we're not really confident about
these reported ages. And notice that users reporting to be
70, have more or less the same friend count, regardless
of reported gender. You're going to reproduce the same plot,
but first let's see if you can create the summary data
to create it. Recall that we can produce the same
summary data underlying this plot by using the D plier package.
We can divide the data by age and gender and
then compute the median and mean friend count for each sub-group.
In this next program assignment you're going to do just that by
using the group by, summarize, and arrange functions from the dplyr package.